good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight this past summer which
is a few months to go before the midterm
elections the bite Administration faced
a huge problem called the economy most
voters vote on the basis of the economy
and how they feel they're doing and how
they feel their country's doing and
their country at the time was not doing
well the U.S economy had just recorded
two consecutive quarters of declining
GDP that's not just an academic
observation that's a technical
definition of a recession
two quarters declining GDP recession
we're not making it up you'll find it in
every economics textbook ever written
it'll look up the one you used in
college
but the byte Administration could not
admit that if they admitted the US was
in a recession they would lose the
Senate they would lose control of both
chambers of the Congress so they had to
lie about it but how do you lie about
something that's so easily defined that
everyone can see
will you just change the definition and
that's what they did they came up with a
new definition of recession so don't
look at GDP that's the old way the
racist way of assessing the economy look
at holistic factors said the way let's
look at the labor market for example the
labor market well then
in June the Bureau of Labor Statistics
gave them ammunition for their case
the Bureau of Labor Statistics issued a
report that showed the labor market was
strong they determined that the U.S
economy and added more than a million
jobs in the second quarter of this year
from March to June a million jobs that's
a big deal it's a big story and of
course Joe Biden wasted no time in
touting it watch
our job market remains historically
strong
our economy created more than nine
million jobs since I came to office in
no small part because the people on this
stage our economy created more than one
million jobs in the second quarter
a million new jobs in the second quarter
despite negative growth wait a second
how you get a million new jobs with
negative growth that seems like magic
how is that possible
but no one in the media asks questions
instead they repeated the White House
line
which was the BLS report the Bureau of
Labor Statistics report showing a
million new jobs proves we can't be in a
recession they all said it quote the
jobs report
suggests the Biden economy is not in a
recession wrote The New York Times and
of course there were other stories like
that too
so on the basis of that and other
factors
they won they now have control of the
Senate and now we get to learn the truth
a million new jobs really the
Philadelphia fed decided to check those
numbers and they found the US economy
did not add more than a million jobs in
the second quarter of this year and said
the net edition of jobs was about ten
thousand
so that's less than one percent of the
job growth the Administration claim
that's not a rounding error that's not a
minor math mistake this is a country
that supposedly sent a man to the Moon
we can do math right
this isn't like thinking about a hundred
bucks in your pocket and finding out you
had 85 this is like claiming you had a
million dollars in your pocket and
finding out you had ten thousand this is
like claiming you were Rich when you
were actually bankrupt this is a lie
so how'd they get it wrong by more than
a million jobs how do they construct
this lie well as it's right we're not
really sure
we now know that BLS numbers didn't just
help Joe Biden though there was another
purpose these fake numbers also gave the
chairman of the Federal Reserve Jerome
Powell a justification to continue
raising interest rates
on the basis of that report they can
raise rates here was Powell just a few
days ago
today the fomc raised our policy
interest rate by a half percentage point
we continue to anticipate that ongoing
increases will be appropriate in order
to attain a stance of monetary policy
that is sufficiently restrictive to
return inflation to two percent over
time despite the slowdown in growth the
labor market remains extremely tight
with the unemployment rate near a
50-year low job vacancies still very
high and wage growth elevated
job gangs have been robust
oh every word of that a lie the
justification is a lie and in fact is
Paul well knows there are seven million
American men of working age who are not
working they're watching the internet
all day
so why are they lying to us about this
well the effects are very obvious go try
and take out a car loan or a home loan
or any kind of loan or if you have a
loan it's got an adjustable rate
watch how much more you're paying per
month so why are they doing this well
the administration wants power to raise
rates because they think it'll offset
the inflation that Joe Biden's policies
have caused
but this is a huge problem for everyone
else raising rates when the economy is
faltering and people don't have jobs if
you keep doing that you could cause an
actual collapse
that seems like the course they put us
on
the bite Administration got the interest
rate hike it wanted even when the labor
market has been flatlining William Beach
runs the Bureau of Labor Statistics
Marty Walsh runs the Department of Labor
they need to explain why anyone should
ever trust the most basic economic
numbers
government issues ever again
and it's one thing to get the numbers
wrong but then to base future policies
on numbers you know are wrong what is
that
that's what they're doing Jerome Powell
should probably answer that question
fairly soon he won't join us tonight
either
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight